tonight we're joined by stephen miller a
former white house advisor who was deep
knowledge of immigration law
and of this stephen miller thanks so
much for coming on
so it is now beyond dispute that the
biden administration
is moving very large numbers of foreign
nationals who are here
illegally into the interior of the
country without the consent
of the neighborhoods into which they're
resettling them
is that legal no it is
absolutely not legal it violates a wide
series of immigration laws that
delineate
in great depth the precise rules and
conditions
for how you can enter the country and
how you cannot enter the country
that's why in fact my organization
america first legal
just argued alongside texas and federal
court that these policies must be
enjoined but what i want to get across
to your audience
to really advance this story is to
understand that what is happening now
is unprecedented and the whole
conversation about border security
up to this point in time has been wrong
this is not
about an administration that is unable
to protect
the border this is about an
administration that in a
very purposeful planned
deliberate painstaking fashion
has turned our border patrol and ice
agencies
into resettlement agencies that is the
word
that everyone needs to know and repeat
this is a
planned resettlement the largest of its
kind
i would suggest perhaps in the history
of the world in terms of the number of
illegal border crossers
being resettled into the interior of our
country in violation of plane law
so there's very little i mean you have
an organization that is using the law to
try and stop this it's happening in real
time it's been happening for six months
without the knowledge of of the 320
million american citizens whose country
this is
but there is someone who can stop it and
that's greg abbott who's the governor of
texas who commands the texas national
guard and of course it's his border over
which
a lot of these people are coming why
wouldn't he shut the border
tonight with mexico and stop this
well i would argue that the appropriate
constitutional remedy
is article 4 section 4 which says that
the government
clearly has the obligation to protect
any state in this country
against invasion and domestic violence
it does not say that that has to be in
the form
of a nation-state actor in other words
the constitution doesn't say
it has to be a state-led invasion it's
any
large-scale unwelcome uninvited entry
into a country
that or to a state that would provide
the constitutional predicate
for exactly what you're describing i
would also suggest it would provide the
constitutional predicate
for the supreme court if they had the
moral courage
to strike down this entire scheme which
is
a blatant violation of our entire
constitutional republican form of
government
let's be very clear when joe biden put
his hand on the bible and swore an oath
to take care of the laws we faithfully
executed to uphold protect and defend
the constitution
to ensure a republican form of
government to every state
he has violated every single one of
those commitments
i'll also add this if that's not an
impeachable offense
i can't imagine what would be no that's
that's right
and and you know that this is
core to their governing plans
because when you mention it they go
crazy and they call you
the worst kind of slurs when in fact i
don't think there is a large group of
people
anywhere in this country of any color of
any political affiliation
who is in favor of this i mean if if
people are in favor of this why isn't
there a bill in the u.s congress just to
admit a million new foreign nationals
every six months
exactly i mean why isn't there what they
are doing is they are doubling
tripling whatever the number is at the
end of the year
who knows it keeps going higher and
higher and higher there's no ceiling
been hit yet
the number of migrants being emitted
into our country every single year
above the already sky-high levels
authorized in federal law
and you're right nobody's going out
publicly not senator manchin not senator
mark kelly
not even nancy pelosi or chuck schumer
saying america
here's why we think we need millions and
millions and millions more migrants
every single year than we already have
and by the way
if possible we'd like them not to have
health insurance we'd like them not to
have college education
and we'd like them to rely on large
amounts of federal government benefits
including free health care services
nobody's making that argument because
nobody could make that argument because
there isn't
any principled argument for it and there
never could be and to your point
about about race hispanic americans
black americans asian americans white
americans every category of american
and by the way every person in every
country in the world that has ever lived
wants a secure border and a controlled
immigration policy
period you must be a white supremacist
yeah it's about consent look
if we want to do this let's tell the
public let's have a debate about it
let's do it democratically they're doing
it
in in the manner of an authoritarian
government that is doing it and hurting
you if you disagree we're not putting up
with it
stephen i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you thank you hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else